reduce to rubble and searched for drone
remnants this was once the home of an
elderly couple
there was one very loud explosion and we
did not really know how it would end for
us
inside what's left of their home oha's
daughter-in-law calls for the family dog
she knows it's likely buried but she's
grateful her parents survived
the home about 40 minutes south of Kiev
is believed to have been hit by a
so-called Kamikaze drone
the family hands over anything that
could confirm the cause of the explosion
attacking civilians is a war crime
Ukraine's prosecutor General's office
has registered more than 54 thousand
possible war crimes and acts of
aggression by Russia
Tuesday will Mark day 300 of Vladimir
Putin's three-day Special Operation the
Russian president was in Belarus Monday
visiting with his closest Ally President
Alexander lukashenka
in Ukraine there are fears Belarus is
getting ready to join Russia after
deploying troops along the border
while addressing a uk-led group of 10
northern European nations the Ukrainian
president implored his allies to keep
sending modern weapons thank you for so
powerfully highlighting
the incredible humanitarian cost to your
people a series of aerial assaults going
back to October have targeted the
country's power grid causing sweeping
blackouts in freezing temperatures
Ukraine's Emergency Services released
dramatic video of a fire at a power
station said to have been recorded in
the early morning hours Ukraine's
National Energy company says it will
soon be able to make repairs at
substations and stabilize the power
supply SEL an American company
fabricated and shipped more than 100
pieces of equipment
specially made for Ukraine's needs
Crystal gemancing Global News London